une centaine de travailleurs s'activent
sur la construction des fondations du
futur édifice de 12 étages on se trouve
sur le chantier du futur hôpital de
vaudreuil-soulage qui devrait être
complétée là d'ici la fin de l'année
2026 et on parle là d'une capacité de
404 lits alors que le taux d'occupation
sur civière des hôpitaux ou de la Motte
région Ouest aussi entre 120 et
150%, le 6 dimensi de lit pour répondre
à la demande de la population qui a
connu un boom de 13,9% entre 2010 et
2020 l'Hôpital du Suroît c'est la mairie
de valleyfile de possède 237 ligues
l'hôpital Anna Laberge à Châteauguay 253
et l'hôpital Berry Memorial à homstown
40 avec l'arrivée du nouvel hôpital
vaudreuil-sous-lange on arrive donc à
une capacité de plus de 910 c'était un
besoin pour les soignants d'offrir des
offrir un système de santé sur notre
territoire d'ici sur l'inauguration le 6
en recruté de 4500 employés au sein du
nouvel hôpital une tâche ardue dans un
contexte de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
c'est sûr qu'un hôpital comme celui-là
les gens vont être contents de venir y
travailler ce que l'on fait nous à
l'intérieur de notre 6 on est en train
de moderniser nos autres installations
alors le soir on est en train de refaire
l'urgence au complet
en fait c'est un nouvel hôpital puis que
si mon département change ça me
dérangerait pas bah c'est pas tellement
plus loin que chez moi ça va juste je
pense déplacer un petit peu mal le mal
de place mais il va manquer de personnel
ici ce qu'on craint c'est l'effet
aspirateur donc s'il y a rien qui est
fait pour favoriser les autres hôpitaux
que celui flambant 9 mais il y a un
risque le nouvel hôpital attire la main
d'oeuvre après 20 ans d'attente on
souhaite que ce nouvel
hôpital avoir si le personnel disponible
pour accompli les attentes ici Gabriel
prout Radio-Canada Montréal